This is Jocko podcast number
104 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
We're going to go right
into Q and. A. Cool.
I don't think there's anything to
discuss. Let's do it. Let's do it then.
It's Q and a. It's Q and a time.
All right, question number one.
You discuss leading and maneuvering
up and down the chain of command,
but what about laterally within your
own peer group where the competition for
advancement is fiercest and your ability
to sit team objectives and implement
some of the tools you discuss is limited.
Okay,
so you,
you absolutely do have to lead laterally
amongst your peers and since you don't
have rank or position,
you have to do it another way.
But wait a second,
since you shouldn't use rank or position
to lead people below you in the chain
of command and since you don't want to
be led by someone that's throwing their
rank and position around,
then guess what?
You need to do the same type of leadership
that you would use up and down the
chain of command to lead your peers.
So what does that mean?
That means you'll help them when you can.
You support what they're doing. You
try and build a relationship with them.
That's what you're
trying to do. Now, this,
this part of this that we're
talking about, the competitiveness,
like if they want to maneuver and try
and make you look bad and jump in the
spotlight and try and get all the
credit, guess what? That's fine.
That's fine.
Let them do it and everyone is going to
see what they're doing and they might
not see it immediately,
but they will eventually be found out.
So do your best to support them.
Do your best to help them.
Do your best to build the relationships.
Make the mission the most important thing,
not the little politics that you're
about to dive into and get involved in.
Don't make that the primary thing.
Make the primary thing
accomplishing the mission.
Hmm?
Think about this.
If you start fighting with them a year,
expending energy on fighting your
own team, that's what you're doing.
Instead of fighting the enemy, it's,
this is a blue on blue situation.
This is a friendly fire is fratricide.
Don't do that.
Disengage from the friendly fire and
focus on how to make the team win.
Hmm.
Take the high ground.
Take the high ground or the high ground.
We'll take you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Another one of those
points that we always say,
I know I do and I always think
this where people are watching men,
they see that and they see
that you see all that stuff,
but let's play this game too.
You know the game where I play
with like who would you hire?
Who would you rather have working for you?
The Guy, the guy, oh, you got four guys.
One guy is helping the other guys out
trying to help them with their mission.
One Guy,
the other end of the spectrum
is undermining people
trying to make himself look
good. Which guy are you going
to promote? Yeah. All Day long.
You know who you're going to promote.
Yeah.
You're going to promote the guy that's
trying to help the team win and not just
look out for himself. Yeah. Yeah.
Fully and consider that
with not just your boss,
but like your peers as well. You
know, even if there's competition,
let's say there's everyone's
competing. Well, yeah,
and you're the guy who's jumping
in the spotlight always, whatever.
Versus the other guy who's always
helping everyone. Even the,
even if they're competing with you,
for sure, I was dumping the spotlight.
He's going to get ostracized if
anything, you know, so man, yeah, they,
they see that stuff, man, that goes
socially. You know what? Now, now,
now answer me this.
When someone sees the world this way,
that means to have a
tendency to think that way.
That means they might have
a tendency to act this way.
So they're going to be especially
cautious if you're looking at everyone,
like while I'm trying to
compete with that guy anyway,
I might be getting screwed over
if I don't, if, if I let him,
you don't get the spotlight right now.
If that's the way you're thinking,
that's the way you're acting and if you're
acting that way, everybody can see it.
Yeah. Don't act that way. Don't act
that way. Be a good team member. Yeah.
The enemy is outside the wire.
Yeah, that's a good one too.
Where the good news about that is like
let's say you are acting in that way,
as long as you can admit it to yourself.
Even if you do have those feelings
inside, but you're like, hey,
I don't want to act like that,
and you start,
even if you know it's kind of against
her feelings and then you start acting
that way slowly and slowly.
Your feelings kind of accommodate
where you don't feel that way anymore.
You'll start to feel that way.
Let's start to realize how you should
act as a human being. As a team member,
as a leader, as a follower,
you'll grow up, you'll mature,
you'll be a good person.
Yeah. Feel the benefits as opposed to just
looking out for yourself at school and
over. The other team. One is against
me, check, kill or be killed.
Next question.
My jujitsu school is small and I'm a white
belt under three months and there are
typically two or three blues and maybe
a purple belt in the class with us.
When I trained her spar with
the blue and purple belts,
I can win the advantage or submit
them more than half the time.
They don't like me because of this.
I like what my is teaching,
but I feel I need more of a challenge.
Should I find more a more competitive
school? Your time is appreciated.
Okay, so there's something very
sus suspect going on. Yeah. Uh,
there's something wrong with the school.
If you're a white belt that
can submit blues and purples,
and I don't know, maybe,
maybe if you're 500 pounds
or just a super athlete,
like your normal person,
even if you wrestled in high school,
maybe even if you wrestled
in college and you,
you've been training Jujitsu
for three months, do,
you should not be submitting purple belts.
That should not be happening. There's,
there's now there's a
small chance of tiny,
tiny chance that they're just being like,
so super cool that they're letting that,
like they're saying, oh yeah, you know,
all that was good.
You know,
you caught me my arm and it
was just giving it to you.
Just too dumb to realize that.
But since you're saying that they don't
like you because you're submitting them,
that, that, that's very unlikely
that they're just super nice. So, uh,
I think you may actually be
in a fraudulent situation
where the school is not a
proper school and I haven't
heard one of these in a while,
but you're a white belt should
not be on the regular sub meeting.
A blue belt and definitely a purple
belt or any purple belts. Yeah.
If there's a massive size differential,
it'd be an occasional occurrence. Yeah.
But on the regular shouldn't be happening.
Yeah. Right. Correct. That. Yeah. I mean,
unless again,
like there's maybe,
and maybe it's a small school,
you know, there's, you know,
a few people maybe like some real
old people or something like that.
Maybe this guy, I don't know how
big he is, but let's say he was too,
I'm getting real specific here.
Right.
What a fees to 25 solid
[inaudible] six to [inaudible]
may or may not have been
a college wrestler. Okay.
Learned a few chokes guillotine.
Yeah. Um, oh, go ahead.
And arm arm bar to 25
college wrestler six to yeah,
he knows basic submissions that,
that, that could be problematic.
And then the rest of the people,
those may be like a 65 year old,
hundred 3,545 pounds. Um, he, you know,
if there's no extreme,
um,
disparity between you and the other
students, yeah, we have a problem.
If there's an extreme disparity,
even then you should go look
around because even if you're,
even if you're a 225 pounds,
six foot two wrestled in college,
most purple belts,
you'd be able to handle you if you've
only been traded for two months. Yes, yes.
Yet so, yeah, even three men,
and not to say my situation and soul,
the, here's proof. I'm not saying that,
but just an example, I was two
when I started. I was two 25
I'd say when I really settled into it,
I lost it got down to about two 15,
two 20. Oh. And I was the white
belt over three months, by the way.
And I rolled with this guy, George was
his name. You might remember him small,
teeny go a
purple belt and no chance I
had with this guy and I was,
so this is more than
three months by the way,
is after I started competing
in there, which is good too.
Yeah. Purple Belts. Yeah.
He's the one who taught me
first bite guard by the way.
For sure. And Jimmy. Yeah.
But yeah, no chance purple belt like
him. You have no chance against. Yeah.
But this is not a big guy. This
is know five, six not, you know,
I think you might be smaller
than five. Six. Yeah. He's
a small guy. I light. Yeah.
Yeah. That's a great example. That's
great example. I'm trying to think.
I mean,
when I started Jujitsu I was 215 pounds.
Who else?
Bigger than 215 pounds.
And Dean was a blue belt.
Just got his blue belt.
Yeah. And I had no chance.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
By the way, I forgot to mention
Dean weighed 174 pounds. So yeah,
it's very similar.
Yeah.
You'd have to like get the disparity
between the two with blue tack to be,
oh, so what do you think it is then? I
think it might be a fraudulent school.
Like how, like what the instructor, the
instructor is not a real black belt.
The instructor knows he's watched enough
youtube to show an arm lock and he can
actually do it on the purple belt
because he he's bigger and stronger or
something and he knows a little bit
better cause it's facing. If you, if,
if you're,
uh,
if you watched youtube and you studied
as hard as I could as you could and you
owned a school and you
trained all the time,
you could be a blue belt level and then
you can beat the other blue belts that
you taught and then gave the boob
cause you gave yourself a black belt.
That's probably what's going on.
That's crazy.
Now whoever this is hit me up again and
tell me what your school is on Facebook
or wherever this question, once
you do that and once you, you know,
I dunno. I Dunno. I mean,
is that a, is that like a,
is that a hard move to be like, Hey,
this is my school and put it out there,
you know,
and here's my instructor.
I mean on one hand you want to think
if the instructor is legit? No, no, no.
That's what I would want to know. I
want it if the, if the guy wasn't legit,
I dunno what I do. I don't have a plan
for that. But if the guy was legit,
I'd come back on here and
say, Oh, here's the situation.
When you found out that
this is what's going on,
you are a six to 285 pound collegiate
NCAA champion wrestler and you studied
sambo or Jew. Like if somebody had Sambor
judo under their belt, that's true.
But you wouldn't even be asking this
question if you had that under your belt
because you know the answer
to. Yeah, man. So yeah,
I think the chance of that is, it's fair.
It's a fair chance, fraudulent situation.
I haven't haven't seen too
many of those lately. Yeah,
because that's a rare thing.
The Internet can mop those up now.
It used to be all kinds of fraudulent
schools. Yeah, it makes sense.
Let me think about it. The Internet
is all over everything. Oh yeah.
You get even halfway fraudulent person.
Yeah. It's like, Oh God, is this guy like,
you know what I mean? Is like, man, you're
really held to the Kohl's, so I dunno.
Maybe two it up.
Yeah,
I was going to say she, we have some kind
of thing on our website where we have,
if you're legit school,
like a Jocko approved school in theory
is how many times a day do you get asked?
I live in Tennessee where
structuring and I live in Chicago.
Where should I train? How many times
do you get asked that? A day. Half.
So every other day is, is that about
okay? You get ask more than that, I guess.
A lot more than you.
Maybe not tons more,
but definitely I could ask repeatedly.
Worst I train.
I live in Jacksonville, Florida. Where
should I train? I live in wherever,
Concord, New Hampshire. Where do I, where
should I train? I live in Salt Lake City.
Utah. You know what I mean?
People are always asking about,
the only risk with that is like, okay, so
first off, we don't know all the schools.
We've probably don't even
know half the schools.
And just cause you say you're under Hixon,
it doesn't mean you're legit. You know,
we'd have to have some sort of an approval
process and then at the end of the
day,
let's say you approve,
I dunno cause some place
and then it then or no, no.
Or people will be like, okay, here's
the page or the website or whatever.
They'll be like, okay, this
school that I'm like looking at,
I like it but it's not on this list.
I don't know.
We didn't get to it kind of thing.
And then it gets kind of like the Dean,
you know? And that way it shouldn't
be that much of a problem. By the way,
there's not that many fraudulent schools.
We're talking about one right now
possibly. But there's not many out there.
Although there are some, they're
like, they're in strip malls.
You drive by like a strip mall and
you see something that says Jujitsu.
Now there's legit schools.
You're him. He's his legitimacy.
It's hard, man. I Dunno. But yeah,
the,
there's actually strip malls is actually
the normal place for Jujitsu schools
now that I think about it.
There's a lot of crazy.
Here's the one that's
straight up in the mall.
Oh that's not a strip mall
than a mall. Yeah, Mall Mall.
I'm going to have to go
visit. Come Prieto. Yeah.
See if you watched that video I did with
them for Metamorris a long time ago.
It's like kill. I forget if it was in the
outtakes or not, but there's this cool,
you know those trains that go around
the mall for the kids. He's like,
I hate that you to train because
it always comes by my academy.
That's funny cause especially
cause computers such a nice guy.
You figured he'd be like, I love
that. That's exactly how he said it.
They totally me, but he says I hate it.
Meanwhile he's smiling and laughing.
It's very interesting.
Dichotomy can wait more
information needed on this academy.
Next question.
I am seeing at work as a very assertive
and aggressive dude and I seem to rub
people the wrong way when they think
I'm upset or frustrated at problems they
they present, which is rarely
the case. I'm just so fired up.
How do I work on Mike hacked while
still being assertive with my team?
You know what, I'm fired up too. Sure.
How you liked that Jagan and
when I was young I, this is
when I was younger. Sure. I
rubbed some people the wrong way.
I know that even when I was a young
kid working on a construction site,
guess what?
I was doing work in too hard,
making people rubbing people the
wrong way. When I got to the team,
those little crew of us that were too
hardcore, we were too fired up. We were,
I would run the o course with my,
with with a rucksack with a 40 pound pack,
a 40 pound sandbag on it.
No one was doing that,
like everyone does it now.
But back then there was a small
crew of us that were doing it,
running with jungle boots all
the time instead of in sneakers.
And I literally got pulled aside by
some of the old guys. And by old guys,
I don't mean nom, I mean old guys
from wherever, uh, you know, from the,
from the nineties or late eighties.
And you know,
I'd get the, hey, you just need to calm
down dude. You know, you need to do that.
And so yeah, maybe I wrote those guys a
little bit the wrong way. Understandable.
But when I got a little older
and a little bit more mature,
I got fired up to actually do a good
job as a leader to actually build
relationships with my platoon mates.
And I got fired up.
Hmm.
For people to,
instead of thinking that I was upset or
frustrated what I was fired up because I
wanted people to think that I was
calm and cool and collected. Right.
So how's that for?
Don't totally different.
It's like when we say default
aggressive. Yeah. And I always say, hey,
you're not being aggressive and
being aggressive towards your people.
It's not yelling. It's being
aggressive towards the mission. I was,
I'm aggressive towards making people think
that I'm not upset and that no matter
what's going on and they just
go, man, Jack was, he's not
going to lose his temper.
He's a super levelheaded right now.
Now that being shit,
that doesn't mean that I was passive.
Sure.
That doesn't mean that I wasn't assertive.
It means that I was
aggressive and assertive,
but I did it with tact and instead
of coming at people straight on,
I flanked them.
I've listened to their little ideas
or I made their ideas come from me,
but they didn't know it. I listened to
their solutions. I helped him support it.
Well,
how you go so far just by helping people
out and helping them with their idea
instead of trying to control them
and make everything your idea.
So that's my advice here.
Relax.
Calm down, focus, get fired up,
get aggressive about being tactful.
Get aggressive about working with people.
Get aggressive about
showing your calmness.
That's what you get aggressive about.
Don't get assertive,
aggressive and create antagonistic
relationships across your company.
Check. Yeah. Good. He said he,
he gets or they think he gets upset or
frustrated at problems that they present,
which is rarely the case. He said, he
said, I'm just fired up. So it's, it's,
it seems like,
and I'm no expert,
but I'm trying to put myself
in a position where like,
I think maybe like it,
it's just a presentation thing,
you know, like yeah, it definitely
has a presentation is aggressive.
Like he's saying he's not
even getting frustrated.
I'm getting frustrated with him
for fracking this, right? Yeah,
like a mindset.
Yeah,
definitely. It's definitely a
presentation thing. No doubt about it.
But so that means you say, okay,
I'm presenting the wrong thing.
I will fix what I'm presenting it.
Do you think actually I think you do
think this or know this or whatever.
Oh, you know how people, they'll, they'll
get nuts or whatever. They'll, they'll,
they'll be aggressive.
They get fired up. Right.
And you know,
the,
whether it be they'll lose their
temper or their behave in a way that's,
that's aggressive towards people and their
justification is not to say that this
guy does this.
I don't know.
But I'm just saying their justification
is I'm just passionate about it.
I'm just whatever, you know. Um, is that,
that's just the justification,
right? It is because, yeah. Yeah.
Like if at the end of the day it is,
it's a joke. It's a justification.
It is also a reality. So think about
it from the other perspective. If,
if you're dealing with someone,
if you have someone on your team that
gets all that they're passionate about
something and it can be problematic
if they don't learn to control their
passions, right? Cause they just get,
Hey, we're gonna make this happen.
And they make bad decisions
because they're so passionate
about making something
happen that there dot did not
doing something logical. So yes,
you could say it's just an excuse and
there's no such thing as a passionate
person. But that actually
wouldn't be true. It's not
an excuse. It's a real thing.
Now, if you are aware of that, then
why do you keep acting that way?
You've got to put your passions
into check. That's what
you got to do. 100%. Yeah.
And I meant more like it's an
excuse for their behavior. You know,
like to me,
I personally,
I think that being passionate about
something that you're into is good way
beneficial of course.
But again,
you know how to say like
there's a difference between
what you feel and how you
behave, you know? So if you're, if
you're super passionate about something,
it doesn't justify it.
Like all this aid rational or emotional
or like loss of temper situation,
behavior. You see what I'm
saying? So, you know, yeah,
be passionate but don't behave
in some crazy off the handle with
agree. So I think that they use their
passion as an excuse for their behavior.
I just got a quick temper
man. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It doesn't mean that you can
act like that's worse. That's
exactly right. Yeah. That's just who I
am. I'm unique in that way. Next question.
My wife told me that she thinks our
11 year old daughter is being bullied
emotionally by some girls at school.
As I drove into work,
I wondered if Jujitsu would give her some
tools to help her deal with emotional
stress and or bullying
that might be taking place.
I think we all know the answer that Daca
will give to this question. Absolutely.
Jujitsu will help 11 years old as a
perfect age for getting in there and you
will learn to,
she will learn to defend herself for
real and physical confrontations,
which will give her real confrontation,
which will give her confidence
because let's face it,
emotional and verbal bullying is
absolutely backed up by a either
clear message of possible violence or a
subliminal message of possible violence,
right? I mean a big group of girl
that's getting picked on the, the,
the underlying messages there,
the implied messages there that it's,
it could go physical if it had to and
when that gets removed because the,
the daughter knows how to
now fight and defend herself,
that starts to impact these
emotional bullies as well. So yes,
absolutely get her training.
I would throw some boxing in there too,
just because that is a
pretty empowering thing.
You've punched in something that
feels good and you, you know what,
while we're at it, let's get some working
out going on. Right. Get a pull up bar.
Get away of the warrior kid
nick. No kidding. Absolutely.
Get her way of the warrior kid.
Don't baby her too much. Yeah,
you gotta be careful of that because
she's your daughter and you say, Oh,
you know, it's so horrible and
these girls are picking a, don't,
don't do that because guess what?
She's going to be dealing with this their
whole life you're going to be getting,
there's always bullies in every
environment, in the school environment,
in the work environment,
in everywhere.
There's bullies and she's going to
have to deal with them. So don't,
don't baby her where she thinks that
you're the one that's going to save her
from it. Um, and I also think should
know that everyone gets bullied.
I got asked that when way the warrior
could came out. Hmm. Someone said,
what did you get bullied?
And they think,
of course I would never get bullied
because I'm a big dude. Well,
guess what?
When I was nine years old,
I was a scrawny little nine year old kid
and every buddy that was 11 was bigger
than me and stronger than me.
Yeah.
And then when I was 11 everyone that was
13 was bigger than me and stronger than
me.
And when I was 14 everyone that was 16
was bigger than me and stronger than me.
So no matter who you are as a kid,
there's always somebody that the bigger
and stronger than you that's going to
bully you if they're a jerk.
So I think she should understand
that she's getting bullied right now.
But that's, that happens to people and
people get over it and get through it.
Okay.
I, I do think you have to be, when you
say that you can't leave the imprint,
you can't overwhelm her and say everyone
gets bullied and you can always get
bullied in the office,
all, you know what I mean?
Like I'm not saying to overwhelm her.
I think that's just like, there's a,
there's a lot. Did you
ever see that movie, that
professional? Which one was it?
The French guy. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a great scene in
that movie where the girl is,
there's like a crazy fight going on
between her parents in the apartment.
They're yelling at each other,
the screaming and just slapping people
that domestic violence is going on and
she comes out and she's sitting in
the hallway. Yeah. And she's crying
and the assassin guy kind of walks up
the stairs and she looks and he looks at
her and she looks at him and she says,
is life always like this or does
it get better when you get older?
And he looks at her and says,
always like this.
So you've got to be careful that that's
not the message that you're sending. Now.
There is some reality to that
statement. Like, yeah, guess what?
Life is always going to be hard and
you do want to give your kids enough
exposure to the hard thing so that
they're not weak and they don't,
they don't go into panic mode when
something tough enters their world.
So that's why things like Jujitsu when
working out are good and exposing them
and letting them experience
some hard things.
But again, you just don't
want to overwhelm her. And
that's that. And by the way,
you might as well start training Jujitsu
to their dad. The mom in there too. Yeah.
Now you've got an excuse to get
down in that gym Jujitsu on,
and I know you that you don't
train Jujitsu. Cause if you did,
you wouldn't be asking this question.
You'd be getting,
getting her training
you making that happen.
So emotionally bullied.
Right. So this is interesting.
She's in the new warrior kid book,
the bully. There's a bully in there,
but he's not a bully like Kenny
Williamson, who's a big, strong bully.
He's a bully.
That's an emotional Bulleit Kinda is d.
And every time there's seems like
there's going to be a confrontation,
he finds a way to weasel out of it.
Yeah. You know, so he'll harass people,
but then he'll get harassed people. He
knows perfectly how to push the buttons.
That's what the marks are dealing with.
This kid named Nathan
James Vaguely from Nathan.
James Causes Problems. Yeah, there's
some layers in that name for sure.
That, so this, this makes a lot of
sense to me. Cause I have a daughter,
four and a half by the
way, goes to pre k pre k.
Is that the Jujitsu school?
She goes, no, no Bruh. Anyway,
so she instructor, she
told him you one day. Um,
she said that her friends,
I'm not gonna say their
name doesn't matter. Um,
she said this friend told
me that she's not my friend.
She's only this other girl's friend.
That's emotional.
That's emotional bullying.
Right?
Then for the four and a half year old
version of it gets way worse at 11,
by the way. And then
probably way worth it. 1516.
It's just my assumption. So what I told
her, not to say this is the right answer,
but maybe the thing to think about.
So my daughter does digit two has done,
you get to double leg choke.
I like it.
Well that's what you want to
say. Yeah, you'd smashed it.
And she's bigger too. She's
bigger than, than everyone,
you know. So she's going to,
no. All right, so what was
your, what'd you tell her?
My daughter is trained to be nice for.
Okay.
So I always have this underlying thing.
No matter if someone be's mean to you,
that doesn't mean you be mean to them.
That makes you mean person.
I said mean people will
be mean to other people.
Nice people tend to not be
mean to other people. Right.
That's really real basic
stuff. Fundamental is for, um,
so you just keep reminding her.
So, uh, so I, I told her, hey,
look, if she doesn't want to be your
friend, then she's not your friend.
And that's okay. Does that
mean you'd be mentor? No,
but at the end of the day, she, I said,
are you stronger than her? And she said,
yeah. I said, are you smarter than her?
She said, yeah, I dunno. She
has or isn't. Here's the thing,
it's the self-empowering thing.
Just like how you said where she knows you
did sue. She's smarter, she's stronger,
she can do more pull ups, she can
do more burpees and stuff like that.
All this stuff. It starts to form in
her head. Hopefully move the goal. Yeah.
Hopefully it'll form in her head that
if they don't want to be my friend,
that's okay. That's no loss to me.
Maybe if someone who was strong like me,
smart like me and whatever, like
me, didn't want to say, well, okay,
maybe that's something, but this isn't the
case. You know? It's kind of that idea.
That's good advice. I think the, the thing
of just saying, oh yeah, that's okay.
Not everyone's gonna want to be
your friend. That's okay. Yeah.
And some people are going to like her
and some people aren't gonna like you.
That's okay. You just be nice
to everyone. That's fine. Yeah.
I've got to ask that question.
When we did the one warrior kid podcast,
a bunch of people asked,
oh my,
I feel like people don't want to hang
around with me. And I was like, yeah,
that's okay. Yeah, that's okay.
You don't need to hang around
with people all the time. I don't,
I don't like even like
hanging around with people.
I didn't say that because I don't
want to turn it over her hands.
I social person like me.
But yeah,
that makes it in that thing or
I think you just said where,
cause my daughter always asks, you know,
did people not want to be your friend?
Or um, what'd she'd like? Bumped
her head real hard. She'd be like,
did you use to bump your head
when you were little? You know,
she always wants to know like, am I alone
in this whole, the whole deal and men,
it seems like you're
really helps what I say no,
I used to do all the time I show her
like my scars and stuff like that and
she'll be like, oh, and you can tell she
feels better about it. That's pretty cool.
It's weird. I think that would help
with a bullying thing and it's good.
Your daughter's smart and so she has the
capability of formulating that question.
I bet a lot of kids might
not be able to even say, hey,
did you bump your head too?
Whereas a parent,
if you just recognize that they probably
feel alone. And so if you say, Oh,
I know you bumped your head, I used
to bump my head too one time. Look,
I got a scar on my head.
It happened to me too.
So they don't make your kids
beg for a partner in the world.
Give it to them. Yeah. Follow the
Echo Charles model of parenting.
And that makes sense too now
that I'm thinking of, because
even as an adult, okay,
so you got a kid and they're
like, hey, did you, I don't know,
did you bump your head like this and
get blood on your head or whatever when
you're little and you're like, you're
like, yeah, and if you add this,
and this is how I
dealt with it, right? Because
a lot of times like you
give him a little path. Yes,
exactly. Right. So you go,
you know you got this poor little kid
bumped her head and it's like, Dang,
I don't even know. I've never felt
this before. There's a lot of paint.
There was blood. Oh, that's scary. I don't
know really how to deal with it. Right.
So of course you go to your dad and
then your dad's like, yeah, Hey, yeah,
I've done it. This is how I did it. This
is how I dealt with it. And she's like,
okay, maybe I can deal with that. And
even adult because adults, we do that too.
You know, like Dang, I'm getting,
I don't know, audited. Yeah.
Getting audited the first time,
whatever Jocko, hey you know,
or you know your friend or
whatever. It's like, hey,
I got audited and this way you can back
to this is like how you deal with it and
all this stuff.
Boom.
You feel better about it indeed and
more empowered and that's on top of the
Jujitsu.
If I got audited I would way rather
know Jujitsu that not by the way here.
Yeah. Chuck, next question. Okay.
I've got a leadership
situation I need help with.
I was promoted to a troop commander
position over a fellow team leader who now
reports to me. He has many
years of experience in a
lot of knowledge. He's very,
he's very bitter and not getting the
promotion at not getting the promotion and
it's letting me know when I include them
in decision making for the troop or try
to tap into his knowledge and
experience. He, he shuts down,
refuses to give input and says that
I should already have the answers.
Since I'm the troop commander,
I know the truth would benefit from his
input in team dynamics would be much
improved if it wasn't so negative.
I've tried to let him know that I value,
I value his experience.
I feel that his input would be beneficial
and that his negative attitude and
bearing and bearing are not acceptable,
is making very ineffective team leader.
I'm,
I'm failing at getting through
to him and I don't want, fuck,
I don't want to fire him for his position.
How can it get him to value
his own position in the
troop and become effective?
Okay,
I actually think you're doing the right
thing and you've opened the door for him.
So I think that's a good
first initial approach. Uh,
but obviously it doesn't
seem to be working.
Now a couple of different courses
of actions you could take.
One of the things you could do is actually
give them some higher responsibility,
right? Give Him, put his team in charge,
put him in charge the whole team.
Sometimes maybe he will step up and start
to lead and see that he's now able to
prove that you have a lot of
trust in him and all that stuff.
There's also a chance,
think about this.
There's also a chance that you might
be coming off as condescending to him.
So imagine this, hey go, I, I
value your experience. Oh No.
So right. You know, the troop would
really benefit from your input.
It's like you're treating them like it's
a key. He's a kid and he's getting that.
Those can come off as condescending.
So we have to put those a
little bit in check as well.
And I think those are a little
bit, you know, you put the,
put the person in charge,
you try that you've opened up to try and
get their input and get them involved.
But it's, it might be coming, it might
be coming across as condescending,
even if it's, even if you're doing it
now, even if you're just saying, hey man,
could really use your input on this thing,
it'd be great.
Even if you're doing it in like a cool way
in your mind, you might be hearing, oh,
I could really use your help. So even
if you're saying it in a perfect way,
it still might be hitting his ears
in a different way. So I don't know.
At this point, I think when I would
do is I would maybe just back off,
I would just go forward,
uh,
treating him like one of the leaders
and expect him to perform as you expect
your leaders to perform.
I think you've made the effort.
It didn't really work and now you have a
job to do and you got to get on with it.
There's also, um, you know,
the world doesn't revolve around
his pouting in his being native and,
and you, you can't let that
happen. Now on top of that,
this guy is a powder
and he's a negative guy.
That's probably the reason he
didn't get selected to be promoted.
What we talked about earlier,
the boss saw that he saw something along
the way where things didn't go his way
and he and he pouted and it was negative
and that's why he didn't get promoted.
Meanwhile, the guy that did get promoted
when things didn't go his way, he's like,
okay cool.
Well we'll drive on with what the new
plan is and that's why he got promoted.
So I would say, move on, do your job,
treat him like you would
treat one of your leaders.
I had be very careful that you don't
correct cause you hear me say like, okay,
I'm gonna treat him normal and now all of
a sudden you're treating him like crap.
Don't do that.
But treat him as firmly and as fairly
as you would any one of your subordinate
leaders. And we have to see
where it goes from there.
He may end up just not being
able to deal with this fact.
I mean there's, there's a reason
why some people get promoted in,
some people don't. And maybe he's one of
these people that can't humble himself,
which is one of our biggest fears in
somebody that's trying to be a leader is
that they can't humble themselves.
And if that's what's going on,
he's going to have a long,
hard road.
And you know who's fault it is going to
be never his never going to be his fault.
It's everyone else's fault. And,
and that's, that'll be problematic.
Yes. Tough one right there. Yeah.
Because in his mind straight up that like,
you're condescending. You don't
deserve it. I deserve it. You know,
and now you're [inaudible] irrigates yeah,
he's already lacking humility.
Was this one time in football,
in junior varsity football and
we're suiting up to play game.
Right. And my bra jade, he
was, he's really good. So he,
you know, you know how you have that
one guy, especially junior varsity,
you have the one guy who
makes the majority of the
touchdowns. Jade was that guy.
So we're suiting up and one
of our team guys on the team,
he was, he was that guy right there.
He was, he wasn't, the thing is,
but he wasn't very value. He wasn't
very athletic. You, you know,
um, and they kind of played the same
position. Judas Rhinebeck, back,
he was a running back to, I think this
goes a full back though. I don't know.
I forget. Um, anyways, so he
goes, he goes to jail. Well,
time to show off again. Yeah.
Holy Cow. So you imagine
the mindset, it's the same.
That guy probably has the same
kind of mindset. Absolutely.
So it's like, man, it's like you can't,
even if you are doing the right things,
how you said, like saying everything all
cool in his ears, it sounds different.
It sounds different
showing off again. Yup. So,
so sometimes when someone isn't
going to hear your words correctly,
sometimes it's best not
to say it miss times,
just keep the mouth shut. And you
ever been in an argument with someone,
but you're completely
trying to deescalate it.
And every single thing you said is getting
taken the wrong way. Be Quiet. Listen,
nod your head anyway. You know
like you're, you're not gonna,
you're not going to convince someone,
you're not going to get through to them.
They're too emotional.
This guy's too negative and yeah,
everything you say is going to be heard
differently and not in a positive way.
Yeah, yeah. Currently called opportunity
cost of addressing it is just
next question.
I'm often given tasks on the fly whereas
many of my tasks are given as a result
of meetings these days and increasing
number are coming from emails or my
manager or client asking
me to do something.
I find myself quite disorganized
when dealing with this.
I'm writing things down when I'm told,
but it's all over the place.
Postits notebook phone.
It's such a,
I don't have a solid method of
keeping track of these things.
I'm guessing that a possible solution
is to write all these things down in the
same place, but I've also tried that
and didn't really make a difference.
I'd appreciate any input or advice
you have on how to record and track
objectives in a functional,
in a reliable manner.
As I'm subjected to a lot of
information each day, week, month,
I'm definitely overloaded to remember
it myself. Discipline equals freedom,
so yeah, a few things. First,
first of all definitely write the things
down in one place and it sounds like
since you're moving all the time or
you're going to meetings carrier,
just a nice little notebook with you and
write the things down as you get tasked
with them. Then on top of that you have
to have a master list of some kind,
either paper or digital.
I'm going to probably recommend digital
to track things overall in a prioritized
method. So if you get tasked something
in a meeting and your little notebook,
you come back, you put it in the
right place in the master task list
and then
like twice a day to consolidate the
information that's in the little notebook
you have into the big master list and
then before you go to bed at night,
you organize those things by
priority on the master list.
Do you put the most important thing at
the top and that's what you're going to
attack the next day?
That's part one.
And how you get these things organized.
Now the part two is you
got to schedule this stuff,
and actually I always say this,
when people have trouble with tasks,
put them on the calendar.
You don't actually Jamie does that for me.
When Jamie's got something for me to do,
she just doesn't email me and say, hey,
you need to do this. And she puts it on
the calendar. So I look at my calendar,
boom, there it is. I got to go do
this. Whatever this task is done.
So put these things on your calendar and
that includes scheduling time on your
calendar so that you can have time to
consolidate your list and do a review of
your lists.
You know whether that takes that probably
take 15 minutes to do and I guess
there's a bunch of apps you can
use and I'm sure people will make
recommendations,
but there's a ton of to do list
apps including there's one,
there's native ones on
all the different phones,
so you could look at that as
a possible of voice recorder.
You can either use the voice recorder
app you have or you can carry around a
little mini voice recorder.
Then you can just take notes with that
and then you consolidate those notes from
your,
from Your Voice Recorder into
your master task list every day.
And then you just got to
prioritize and execute
to it pretty straight forward.
Write the stuff down and
put a little bump. I was,
I was put little boxes in front
of everything. Do you understand?
Like when I have a task I put a little box
so you can check. I can check it. Yeah.
Yeah, it makes bro. You're obviously
compared to me a master at that.
Like all that is like, Dang,
you can do all that bro. I'm,
I'm on the flight just like this guy,
this person straight up,
like on the fly in new stuff comes up.
Same bold.
Be surprised at how much more you could
get done if you actually made a list of
things you were supposed to
do. How's this? How's this?
I make lists and I still try and
turn and nail it down. Right.
I'll make a list. I even, okay, so I have
a book that Jamie gave me by the way,
a book a to do list book and then I help
you is trying to encourage good habits
and then I have my phone
and then I have this,
oh and then have just the regular thing
on the paper and then I do this thing
where I'll open word and have it on my
side screen and I'll put the list there
for the day.
It'll just be upstairs at their my face
and strangely that has proven to be the
best one because I'm doing,
I'm in here.
I see my mistake right now
that I'm telling you this,
I put it on on the book that Jamie
gave me, write my to do list.
I put it there and then consolidate
your list. It's on that book.
There's one on the, on the phone,
which is different now by the way,
your master list,
there's some apps
that may, so it doesn't matter
if you put it in your phone,
if you put it in your computer,
I mean obviously you've,
it's if it's on paper you need to
transpose it into digital format.
But there's, there's things that too.
Yeah, you need to consolidate a list here,
have master list of things
that you're trying to do and then I need
to attach myself as far as the routine
goes to look at that list.
You know all like that's why you
schedule it, which is what I just said.
That's why you put it on your schedule.
Hey,
every day when I sit down for lunch and
we would do a five minute review of my
lesson,
make sure I'm on track.
That gives you the afternoon to catch
up on anything you might've missed and
just get rid of my other list.
Cause half of it is me trying
different methods out there,
right in the middle of carrying
out one other meth he at all.
So it's always a bad thing
about trying different,
trying to combine a bunch
of different methods,
what you're doing when you do that as
you're looking for the easiest way.
And I'll tell you the funniest,
clearest example of that.
When Dean first started fighting and he
was going through his various stages of
trying to figure out how to cut weight,
and he already cut weight cut
white in high school as a wrestler.
So he knew how to cut weight.
But what happened is people would come
along and say, hey, there's this trick.
I use that trick and there's this
trick and there's that trick.
And he would try these other all these
little tricks out and you would try them,
you know,
at the same time.
And that's exactly what you can guess
what you don't when you try all these
different,
because what you're really doing is
you're looking for that something that
sounds easy. Cool. Yep. I'll do that. It
was the, you know, for Dina was like, oh,
I'll go on the Epson salt bath
and the hot tub. And then it was,
oh,
you know,
and I'll drink just distilled water for
x amount of days and it was all these,
which all of these things are viable,
right?
We know that there are viable options,
but there's,
you have to use them in conjunction
to have to be, you have to,
you can't just like pull the pull
whatever little piece you want and think
you're going to be good to
go. No, you've got to do,
you've got to follow the system,
take one and go with it kind of thing
and what you're trying to do is you're
looking for things that sound the easiest
and that's what you're trying to do.
The easy path,
the easy path over here,
but meanwhile you've got three
different paths all effective.
Meanwhile you're jumping
from one path to the others.
That's exactly what I'm doing with my to
do lists. I would like for to do lists.
Okay. You needed to do list that says
consolidate all of your to do list.
That's step number one.
Then I got to remember that.
That's the list that I'm checking.
Then I got to remember to check
it because you know how you,
cause you always have that to do
list in your brain. You always do.
You know you're like, oh I've got that
thing. By the way it's on my mind.
One in my brain is real solid.
What?
Like the the the to do list in
my brain is really, really solid.
Like I know what I have to do.
The only the,
the things I have to write down are things
that are outside of this. Outside the,
the,
the parameters of daily situations.
Like let's say there's some
admin thing that only comes up.
Well if it comes out super
rarely I'll remember it.
But if it's an admin thing that
comes up once every quarter, yeah,
I probably won't remember that.
It's not,
it's not so far outside that I'll
remember and it's not in the routine so I
don't remember it.
So I got to write
that thing now.
That's what's on my list.
So do you write down the list
that's in your head? On the, on the,
on the written list,
I'll write down the things that I know are
are
subject to being forgotten because
the other things I don't forget them.
Yeah, so you're just, I don't forget
the hard core like company. If I have a,
let's say I'm going on a trip of a con,
like if I'm going on a regular trip,
I'm going to go to company that I work
with and they're in Atlanta and I'm going
to fly out there for three days.
I don't even,
I don't even have to think about that.
Everything that I do is,
is the the work I'm doing, the prep I'm
doing, everything I do is this standard.
It's a standard operating procedure.
Even that,
even the things I'm going to
bring with me, it's the same.
I went on a one day trip to Vegas
the other day, like in and out.
I didn't even stay the night and I had
the same suitcase that I take when I go
on a five day trip.
Like it doesn't matter to me.
I'm not changing any standard operating
procedures. I got there and they said,
aren't you leaving today? I said, yeah.
He said, why did you bring a suitcase?
This is how I,
this is how I travel.
This is the standard
operating procedure for me.
I'm not deviating from it
whether I'm going for one day,
but like a nine hour trip to Vegas
or a five day trip to Atlanta.
Guess what? It doesn't matter.
I'm carrying the same thing
cause that's what I do.
So if it's something like that, I
don't need to, don't even need things.
Some things don't make my list because
they're already in my head of my list in
my head is solid.
It's things that are outside the bounds
of the standard operating procedures.
Those are things that'll make the list
and that makes sense for this question.
It's kind of this question cause
he's getting stuff on the fly.
It's getting stuff on the fly. He's got
a piece, got write this stuff down. Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I think we're all kind of the same way
in that way where you're going to have
one,
two,
maybe three things on your mind that no
way I'm going to forget this, you know,
kind of thing. But man,
those lists though,
you get to really to choose one path
and stick with it and then remember it.
That's the thing. I think
that's my problem. I know that.
Next question.
How did you deal with losses in Jujitsu,
Jujitsu day today?
Losses look assuming in a tournament,
right?
I just had my first tournament and
got the floor wiped with me. Yeah.
Welcome to Jujitsu. The obvious
thing is you got beat. Good.
You learned, I think we may wave
wedding, we've gone through that one.
And then really, you know, how did you
get beat? What areas where you're weak in?
Then you analyze and improve in
those areas. And that's Jujitsu,
right?
Don't dwell in in,
don't dwell in your loss,
but learn from it and move forward.
And actually speaking of Dave Burke,
I was talking to Dave Burke
and he was explaining to me
his psychological current
status in Jujitsu. So He's,
however he's, he's basically my age. I'm
40 might be 45 or something like that.
But he's been
basically a master of kind
of everything he's done.
And you know what I mean? I
mean, he's like, like factually,
if you look at his life,
he's been top gun top gun instructor.
He was telling me that during
Operation Southern Watch,
which was pre you know,
post first Gulf War
pre nine 11 he was the,
he was one of the very,
very,
very few guys that actually
dropped a live bomb.
And you know, back in the day
when no one had any experience,
he was a guy that had really,
really done it and,
and then he was talking on top gun
instructor it, you know, you're just,
and then after 35 f 22 just all that
stuff that he's done and he was,
he was telling me that
like if he thinks about it,
he gets a little bit bummed out because
he's just starting Jujitsu right now.
Obviously it's in his head
and he's thinking, oh,
I'm never going to reach the highest
level that I should or could if I had
started younger. And so he, if he,
it's almost like if he thinks about that
too much, it's almost like all that,
I'm just not going to do it. You
know what I mean? But depending,
he immediately was like,
of course I know that I'm going to do
it and I'm going to be as good as I can.
But
you know that that's,
that's also the way life is.
Right? Just like when you,
how do you deal with losing in life? You
learn from your mistakes, you move on,
you don't, well, it's the same thing as
you did to, you study your weaknesses,
you figure out what you can do, you
fix those problems, you move forward.
Don't dwell on it
fast. That's it. Yeah.
Got Beat. Good. Yeah.
Actually put it into perspective
even more. We're okay.
So this is just an assumption.
I know I just had my first tournament.
I'm assuming white belt, maybe blue
belt. Okay. I'm assuming. Yup. You know,
it just doesn't seem like
at Brown belt or something,
you just turn this question or you're
not in your first tournament typically.
But I mean you never know,
but you wouldn't even have this
in your mind where it's like,
how do you deal with loss? You, you won't
have that in your mind as a brown belt.
Like, you know, it's a
little bit more clear anyway,
so unless you,
this is like scarred you for life.
I lost and I'll never compete
ever again kind of thing. Um,
I think this is, this is a good way
to think of it where, you know how
it's like,
I dunno your first girlfriend and like
junior high or something dumped you. Like,
at the time it seems like,
Dang, I got dumped or whatever.
And then when you're an adult you're
like, oh my gosh, same thing, Jujitsu.
So like when you're a white belt
and you lost your fridge, you know,
as a white belt and you're, you know,
I dunno, a blue belt, pro, belt belt,
black belt, whatever. And you're thinking
about your first tournament. You're like,
oh my gosh, who cares?
It doesn't matter at all.
And really when you kind
of put into perspective,
unless you want to dedicate
your life to competing,
the tournament's don't really
mean anything. It's just fun.
And if you take the fun out of it by
putting everything on that one tournament
that you're currently doing, probably
you won't, won't want to do it.
And you'll kind of think that that's kind
of what competing is about. It's not.
So if you're,
if you lose your first tournament,
my first match and my first tournament,
I lost.
I didn't get the floor wiped with me,
but I, that's a common thing. Yeah.
You think back on it. And
not only do you, well,
I think you'll always remember the
first one, but, um, as far as like,
whether you want or lost,
it doesn't matter at all.
Totally doesn't matter at all.
And you'll find that the more you compete,
the less it'll matter.
And then do you get to competition?
Really?
Unless you're like really dedicating
your life to being a good competitor.
Um, Jujitsu competitions, you're gonna
win some and you're going to learn.
You do some yes. And you
learn. And Learn, oh my gosh,
that doesn't work if I don't
time it correctly, or Dang,
that doesn't work because
that's not a real submission.
I only do it to smaller guys and they
tapped because it's uncomfortable kind of
thing. But in [inaudible] it doesn't, you
learn these kinds of things, you know,
but it's not even gonna matter.
Like dealing with the loss.
It's not even going to be a factor because
you just got to know that's just part
of it. And really, who cares when you're
kind of just starting out. You know,
like if you ask
like a top level black belt competitor,
you know, did you win? Ask coiler. Okay.
Coiler right.
He tells the story about him in her hoists
and went into their first competition
there. Dad said, if you win,
I'll give you 10 bucks.
If you lose,
I'll give you 20 so it
takes the pressure off.
Like it's not that big of a deal. You
know, if you lose, boom, you know,
it's all good. That's what that was for.
And heuler loss hoist one boiler loss.
He got the 20 bucks and he's
like, sure I would've, you know,
had heuler one of the greatest
legendary guys lost his first one,
puts it in perspective.
It doesn't matter at all and got $200
you're not always going to get the 20
bucks, but just say it, I'm, yeah,
it doesn't matter. It won't matter.
And you're going to think the
same thing like high school,
like the stuff that happened in
high school. When it happens,
it seems like it's a big deal, but then
when you're an adult you're like, ah,
this is an adult. Cool. It's
a cool memory, but you know,
could have been better.
Anyway, next question. Hello, Mr Willing.
I'm currently deployed to Iraq
as an east six in the army.
I have listened to your podcast
and really enjoy your stuff.
Especially different
discipline equals freedom.
I know as a sergeant and as a leader,
your focus isn't to be liked.
However your soldiers should respect you,
respect both you and your rank.
My question is how
do you tell your soldiers
to do the small stuff?
Tedious stuff like taking out
the trash and still be like,
all right, well first of all, if
we want to get respect from people,
we have to give them respect for sure.
Thinking about this,
think if you took out the trash
sometime you don't think if you're the,
you're the boss,
but you see that the trash is getting
overfilled and you just grab it and take
it out.
Yeah.
There's thinking about what that does
is thinking about what that does,
the attitude of the guys,
if you took out the trash,
you, you maybe in your mind, do
you think you'd be losing respect,
but you actually wouldn't be at all. In
fact, everyone looks at you and goes, oh,
he's a good guy.
He's taking out the trash.
It was little full then he's taken care
of it. So maybe if you're insecure,
you'd think you'd lose respect.
But I think if you're secure in your
ability to lead and if you know that doing
some tedious stuff is going to
make you guys appreciate you
than to me that means it's
kind of worth it. Right. Um,
another example, you know, we
talked about taking out the trash,
but like what if the platoon
space has to be cleaned?
And on Friday you, you just say, hey
guys, you guys can go ahead and roll out.
I got this right. There's a
chance. They're like, hey boss,
we're not leaving.
Where are we know will help you there.
There's of course there's a chance they'd
be like, oh, that's awesome. Thanks boss.
And they bail
over time.
That might be if they don't respect
you at all, they might bail.
Now in order to regain the respect, do
you make them stay in Boston around more?
Does that increase the respect for you?
You see, you see how interesting it is,
is that if you go, hey guys,
that's cool, I'll do it.
And you're working hard and you still
got to maintain the discipline and you
don't take any slack. But at
the, it's the same balance.
It's the balance we talk
about all the time. So
the more that you treat
them with respect to more,
they're gonna respect you and they're
going to know that you're not,
you know, too high and mighty. Yeah.
They're going to know that you're down
to earth. When I was a platoon commander,
tasking to commander, I picked up brass,
I cleaned the ranges with the boys.
That's just the way I operated. And I
would recommend that kind of attitude.
It didn't make people think,
oh,
Jockos doesn't have anything better to
do that actually knew I had stuff to do.
But what am I going to do?
Pick up brass with the boys.
Build the relationships, set the example
they're gonna respect you for it.
Makes Sense. At the end of the day, do
you have something better to do? Right?
Cause the whole, in the big picture, it's
like how you say like that's a leader.
Sometimes you literally have
something literally been no, no.
Like sometimes you literally pay,
the boys were up brass and guess what?
You got a meeting with the commanding
officer, you gotta go, do you? You know,
sometimes we,
you actually do.
And what's cool is tactically is,
and you heard us say this at
the, uh, FTX and were up in Utah,
if you see the leader doing something
menial, what you should do as a sub,
as a follower, step up and say, hey,
echo, I got this. You can go and lead.
That's what, that's what you want.
That's what I want to do for my leader.
I want to take things off my leader's
plate as much as possible. Now
the more you try and you just
have to build those relationships,
the way we build those,
if you don't have anything better to do,
then you get down there and do
you help you help clean up the,
do you help pick up the brass?
Yeah. That's the way it is.
Notice that about you and Lafe too,
where you know,
like I'll have my camera
equipment and you know,
lights or whatever and it's not
a bunch of stuff, but you know,
you're always like,
oh,
you'll like grab something and you
don't like it when I grab your camera.
Don't touch it, don't touch it.
But, and when it's just me and you,
it's kind of like cool cause we're
just kind of friends or whatever.
There's no perceived or no
like hierarchy kind of thing.
Like you're, you know, but let's
say like at the muster, whatever,
it's obvious like you guys have a specific
job. I have a specific job, you know,
kind of thing. And meanwhile
you and, and life will,
like if I'm around,
I'm carrying something that you'll always
like grab something or, or say, hey,
you need, you know, you didn't
though at the Utah thing,
he's like, oh, are you good?
I'm like, Bro, you're the
instructor here kind of thing.
That's what I'm thinking in
my head. And um, and yeah,
you guys always offered to
like help. Really? Interesting.
I'm like almost offended.
Like Bro,
like do I look like I need help because
you shouldn't really be asking me,
you mean for
apple?
But there were bright,
very capable individual. Yeah. And
the small tedious stuff.
And the other thing is you explained
to why it's important, right? Yeah.
About to answer. We give all
the time. Why is it important?
Why is it important that the
platoon huts clean? Well,
cause I want you guys to have time off
over the weekends and not be stuck here
cleaning.
Cause the commanding officer came in
and saw that this place look like a hell
hole. Okay, well that makes sense to us.
We understand why you want us to clean
now you want us to clean so that we can
have time off. You want us to
clean or you want us to train hard?
Do you want us to do this?
Cause cause we want to be ready for combat
because I want you guys to be able to
come home to your families.
Make sure they understand why
they're doing what they're doing.
And if there's no reason why, if
the reason, I mean even cleaning,
even taking out the trash,
there's a reason for that. Right?
There's an actual reason for that.
We can't just have junk everywhere.
So explain why participate when you
can build the relationships with your
troops, you'll be good.
Yeah, that works by the way.
Thanks for your service and brother,
I hope you're having a good time
over in Iraq, getting after it.
Second that for sure
that works for kids big time
explaining why you do it.
And if you really want to dial in,
the effectiveness is make that reason
somehow tie it to their interests,
their direct interest. Cause sometimes
kids can't see the big picture. You know,
like if I say you got to
clean your room and you know,
otherwise your room be messy
and then maybe you know, um,
later in life you might be
comfortable with a messy room,
might get in the way of your effectiveness
at a little four or five year olds.
They're not gonna understand
that. And they'll be like, cool,
that sounds like terrible,
but they won't feel it.
But if you tie it into their like direct
interest as a four or five year old or
however old the kid is,
it works really
good.
What if you don't clean your room and
there's a fire and I come in here to get
you,
but I trip and fall down and then you die.
That's one way.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. All right. Yeah. I don't
know if I'd say that, but it's cool.
Good time for one more
here. Yeah, I think so.
Jocko. In war, the enemy is clear,
but in life,
in business,
not so easy to identify any tips?
Well,
um,
I mean, first of all, that
is not a true statement.
And in, in war, the enemy is
not always clear, not at all.
The enemy,
the enemy can be hard to identify,
very hard to identify the enemy's gonna
use camouflage to conceal themselves.
They're going to use deception to,
to distract your attention.
They're going to blend in with
the friendly civilian populace,
and they're going to take advantage
of your benevolence, right?
In fact,
the enemy is going to do absolutely
everything in its power to obscure their
position,
to hide their purpose,
to even mask their identity.
So it is not easy to identify the enemy
in combat in war.
So what you have to do is you have to
control what you can control, right?
You gotta be prepared. You've got
to train, you've got to study,
you've got to rehearse.
You've got to remain vigilant.
You've got to maintain discipline in
everything you do so that when the enemy
does reveal itself,
you have the ability to out think it,
to out maneuver,
to fight the enemy.
And it's actually the same
thing in business, right?
The enemy can be hard to identify.
Your competitors aren't
broadcasting their next move,
okay?
You don't know what the
market's going to do.
You can't be certain about the next
trend or the next down turn to the next
bubble that's gonna burst.
You can't know those things.
So you have to do the same thing.
You have to control what you can control,
which is you
gathering intelligence. You've got to
analyze the metrics that you can track.
You got to train yourself and your team
to be prepared for both the known and
also be prepared for the unknown.
Figure out what the
likely contingencies are.
Then have some plans
to execute if those contingencies occur.
Maintain discipline as an organization
so that you have the flexibility and the
responsiveness to maneuver effectively
and efficiently when the unpredictable
actually happens.
So instead of suffering and
falling apart in the chaos,
you can take advantage of it and when
and
that's business and life is the same.
The enemy is not always clear in life.
It can be hard to tell who's
going to try and bring you now
or what is going to bring you down.
There's distractions.
There are things out there
that will do you harm,
that are so camouflaged.
You can't see them at all.
There are deceitful people.
There are accidents that can occur and
diseases that take root and there's bad
luck.
And there's Murphy's law and there's times
when it seems that the whole world is
against you.
The whole world
is the enemy
and the same rules apply.
Control what you can't control.
You train hard,
learn,
maintain the unmitigated daily
discipline in all things.
Train hard physically and mentally.
Push yourself so hard that you become
accustomed to the stress you get used to
it
every day.
Make yourself stronger and faster and
smarter and better so that when the enemy
does finally climb out of the
shadows and expose himself to you,
you are ready.
You are waiting
and you can relish in the tunity
to attack and fight an orderly
decimate and destroy him.
Okay.
And I think
that's all I've got for tonight.
So
Echo,
maybe you could,
okay.
Help us figure out how we can support
ourselves and perhaps be better prepared
for the enemy yeah.
Of whichever kind and whenever it
exposes itself so that we can smash it.
And if you want to do that,
you can also do that while
simultaneously supporting this podcast.
They want to of course, or we could just
have a bunch of advertisers on here,
listen to us talk about
stuff that, sure. Yeah, yeah.
Either way. Hey, I'm here to do
one of the things I was talking to.
Uh, actually that's, that's
true. That where, you know how,
you know, you say that a lot and it's
easy, especially me. I go, what do I say?
A lot like, be ready, you know?
Yeah. You know, um, you know,
prepare you stronger, faster, smarter,
and you don't like a lot of things
after a while, you hear it like enough.
A lot of times, a lot of times, a
lot of times, sometimes it clicks,
but then every once in a while you'll,
it'll like leave a mark. No, no, no, no.
The opposite. Sorry. The
opposite. Like, um, okay. You
know? Yeah, I get it. I get it,
I get it, I get it. And Blah Blah,
blah, blah. The next kind of, yeah.
And these things, like when you
really think about that one, like we,
there was a saying, I don't
know, I'm sure it's not new.
When I heard it was like
chance favors the prepared man.
Is that the correct fortune?
Favors the brave.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, what are
you looking for? That,
that quote is like basically some chance.
Favorite though.
The one that I heard it was chance
favors the prepared man. Yeah, for sure.
So it's all,
it's all the same variations of that one.
I went straight to the fortune
favors the bold or brave. Yeah.
Prepared. Right. So if you're scared,
you know you're going to seem to have
more luck with victory and all this other
stuff. Right. So it's like,
you know, in any circumstance,
like if you take working out working
that as like the easy one because like if
you're in shape or you're,
you're strong or if you're not weak
or if you're not incapable, you know,
like you don't work out so your backs
out or something like that or compare it
with being strong,
being strong is always more beneficial
in pretty much every single situation is
them being weak. Yes. True. Or being
in shape, you know, being healthy,
being zero, order, being
smarter. Yeah. Yeah.
You hesitated,
but that's,
it's always good to be strong and
occasionally it's good gum. No,
not saying there's not one of
the, it's, it's one of those
things where where are,
where the result of working out and
being strong is always going to add a
tangible benefit to most of this. Pretty
much everything you do in your life.
That about being smarter. I'm not saying
that I'm not just going to jump into,
yes, that's true too, because I didn't
think about it. I thought about this.
Let's see. There you
go. Well, nonetheless.
But I think that's one of
those things where we kind of,
it's my opinion that what
you just said there is,
should be taken to heart
hundred percent concur. Yeah.
Not just some cool thing like let's face
it. That sounded good. That sounded cool.
But in there I don't, I don't
listen to it cause I'm saying, yeah,
I thought it sounded dope,
but it's absolutely true.
And you know, and there's little
micro struggles, you know, in life.
Let's face it. I know you have some
of my clothes, all my struggles or my,
but guess what? No problem.
You know, no factor, no factor.
I was filling up jugs
and I used this example.
I'm going to do it again.
You know why? Cause it's it,
every time I fill up
jugs I think about this,
the struggle is real water jugs.
They're like, well, 40 pounds, right?
I think like seven pounds. I think it's
an eight pounds per gallon. Seven. Okay,
so they're five gallons each.
Yeah. Okay. That's, you know,
but no problem. You know, if can do it.
No, I don't need a cart. Take care of him.
You know kind of thing.
Do you carry just one in each arm yelling,
any Chan it see what it is. See what
I'm saying? They'll see how you're like,
that's nothing.
That's nothing.
But for a lot of people who don't
work out and I was like that,
that's not nothing.
It's something
nonetheless. I'm just saying
like if you're prepared. Okay,
so tell us how we got bless
struggles. Yeah. Okay,
so first thing you do is maintain,
maintain your, your, what do you
call it? Your, your, your structure.
Foundational structure.
Make sure you're not breaking down,
starting with your joints. As always,
say chocolate has some supplements.
Krill oil and glucosomine can
Drayton supplements, Jocko,
Super Krill Krill oil
and what's called joint warfare,
chocolate joint warfare.
That's Glucosomine conjoint and some
other good stuff for your joints.
It's funny.
The other stuff is
actually really beneficial.
So go to origin main.com and read so
that you can realize the benefits that
you're getting because it's good for you.
Yeah,
and I'll go beyond just good for you.
It's the kind where,
and I'm saying this firsthand,
firsthand account. My account
before you take this,
you're going to have joint pain.
And even if nonfactor joint pain,
I was talking to Dave Burke the other day,
Dave Burke's popular tonight.
Yeah.
So Dave Burke asked me about
Krill oil just in general.
He's like, well, I don't have joint pain.
Like most of the workouts and
Martin workouts, they do see the,
and that's the thing. So I was
like, I was kind of like that too,
where I didn't know and I don't
want to be the guy who's like, no,
you do have this problem. And they're
like, Bro, I don't have this run. No, no,
you do and you need this product.
You know, I don't, I'm not,
I didn't want to be that guy and you want
to come off like that guy. So I'm like,
yeah, you'll save coming off
like that for the podcast.
No,
he made a good point.
If you don't have like joint
pain or whatever, um, then yeah,
you won't have the exact experience I
did because I did have joint pain and I
joined p and in places that I didn't kind
of realize it. You just feel like, oh,
don't Dang, I'm still
better. That's your baseline.
You get used to the pain on top of the
fact that it had pain that I didn't, I,
that I knew it wasn't normal,
you know,
just more stiff now that I'm getting
older or whatever. But nonetheless,
I was like, Dude, look an old
I think, how do I look cool?
You know, it's my birthday in
two days, by the way. Anyway.
Sure. You could not have
joint pain, but the,
even before I had like any kind of
pain from working out or whatever,
from joint or in my joints or whatever,
I should have started taking
it before that I should have.
And I'm not saying people will take it
or what. I'm not saying that necessarily.
Um, so Dave's question to me was,
should I start taking it? I said yes.
Yeah, hundred percent. It's good advice,
but I did have to let them know if you
legitimately or not having joint pain,
don't think that it's going to be a
miracle thing. Like it felt like for me,
that's the point. Nonetheless, it's the
best stuff because it's from Jocko, right?
Yeah. Well it's the best stuff cause
it's the best stuff it happens to be,
happens to be.
Anyway,
go to origin main.com for this super
krill oil and Jocko joint warfare on the
tops is labs. I always see that it's
on the front too, so it's real obvious.
Just go there or [inaudible] dot com
there's also some geese if you're still
wondering about what gay to get.
Don't wonder anymore.
Straight up. Yeah. And there's actually,
there's actually no comparison
to be quite honest with you.
There's no comparison.
Every other g is not made here
in America with American hands.
American material.
Yeah.
So there's no compare. You can't
compare. Can you literally can't compare.
There's no comparison.
And I don't want to turn this into like,
you know,
putting down any other geeky company.
So I'm not necessarily going to do that.
But let's face it,
in certain manufacturing
industries, I guess
brands, a lot of brands,
they go,
they all go to the same stuff.
Plier in Pakistan, they are aware of the
things come from the same place. Yeah.
And that's why I said there's
actually no comparison. Yeah.
And it's not just no comparison
cause it's made in America.
It's no comparison because it's been
designed from the ground up by people that
do Jujitsu.
Yes.
By people that do Jujitsu on the
daily at origin, the factory.
Then you know what the next building is,
the origin training facility.
So it's like,
it's like we're going to put on our gies
and train and then we're going to do,
make sure that it's squared away
from, by the way, it's not like,
oh well we want it to look like this
and we'll just have to use some random
material.
We'll design the material,
design the weave of the material so
that it's optimum for Jujitsu and that's
what will make and sell. So
there is no comparison. Yeah.
And he was like no one else doing
anything close to that. Yeah.
The closest would be, hey
we're, we're making it. Look,
we're putting a color to it or
putting a patch somewhere or you know,
that's the closest you could do to say,
and we're doing something like this. Yeah.
No one is designing from the ground up
from the material up from the threads
themselves. Yeah. The typical scenario,
by the way, it's not just the geese,
the rash guards, same thing. Yeah.
The material created by origin.
Yeah. Yeah. The typical scenario is
you get, you know, hey, I'm been to,
and you'd be surprised man.
Even these like kind of established
brands like it doesn't matter which ones,
whatever. But there'll be like, hey, yeah,
let's do you know, let's make this g,
oh by the way,
let's get the same blanks that we use.
Is everybody always been getting and
that everyone else and let's just put a
cool stitch on there or
something or patch or,
or design doesn't just the
way it typically works.
Not even necessarily that
there's anything wrong with it.
Cause if you like you eat like your gay.
That's good. That's how I am. But yeah,
the origin, once you kind of put
it on, I will argue that you're,
you're going to kind of understand my
opinion on the last or do you mean.com
that's the one,
that's the good one.
Also for legit fitness gear.
Go to on it.com/jocko good
kettle bells on there.
They got some star wars Kettlewell's.
That's cool. Yeah. See
that's the thing, man.
You don't really care that much about
these, these cool kettle bells. I do.
Nice about it. I do. I think
they're dope nonetheless. Um, yeah,
kettlebells on there. I got into
kettlebells awhile ago. Very glad I did.
Wish I had done it earlier.
Did I get you into kettlebells? Yeah, I
got you into Krill oil and kettlebells.
Yeah.
Okay. Give it up. But both. Yeah,
both. Not necessarily. Not actively.
I got you in the metcons to make cons.
Yeah. You used to not do metcons.
I remember you sent me a text
sometime like what was like,
what's the deal with this, this
metabolic conditioning? He said,
what should I do and I
just sent you in there.
All of a sudden you started doing metcons
and your cardio on the Mat got a lot
better quick too,
by the way.
Metcons metcons with
kettlebells and Krill oil. Ooh.
That Combo right there.
Anyway,
and there's a lot of cool other exercise
stuff on there like creek kind of
create more creative stuff. Um, you
know, keep your workouts interesting.
That is on at.com/chocolate checkout.
Some stuff on there.
They got some really good stuff.
Really good stuff.
I'd use [inaudible] smart with that where
he's always like pushing like the good
stuff, you know. You know
also Jack was a store.
It's called Jocko store.
Jacqueline's store.com. It has,
if you want to get these shirts that we
make and we have been to make their good
shirts do,
they're not like free shirts.
You know the free ones that you
like. Cool. And you never wear it.
It's not that kind of very wearable. I
made it a point to make. I'm like good.
You know, it's the women's stuff
on their rash. Guards, patches,
hoodies.
I know it's getting colder now.
Places they're thicker.
Hoodies does it called Nicola?
You right now it is actually.
It is.
It's like 60 there's no other
topical. Why you right? No, not quite.
It's a big island. Yeah. Dang
it. Monica. I just revealed my,
not everyone knows Hawaiian. That's
all right, but you're coming to me.
That's a man. I might have to suspend
your my co E-card for a little while.
They'll have to now
anyway.
We've got some hoodies for people who
are in places other than Hawaii or if
you're on Mauna Kea, thicker
hoodies, all this stuff. Anyway,
I'm not saying buy stuff.
I'm saying [inaudible] check it out.
If you'd like something, get
something. It's a good way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already on iTunes and stitcher and
Google play. However you listen to the
podcast who's subscribed seems obvious.
I know, but if you haven't
subscribed, good way to support.
Also on Youtube we have a youtube channel.
There is various reasons
to subscribe to Youtube,
but the main one I think main two is
if you'd like the video version of this
podcast and you like little excerpts,
whether we put some music behind
them. When I say we, I mean me,
it's a music guy, them and
some various effects or not.
There's excerpts,
you know,
little shorter than the whole version
of the podcast and you can share him,
listen to him or whatever. Let
quicker anyway, subscribe to Youtube.
This is what I'm saying, if you want,
and if you do want to and you do,
it's a good way to support
also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is.
It's an album on iTunes
that you can get with tracks
that on your campaign
against weakness on the path,
trying to get in better shape.
You're trying to get in shape.
You want to maintain your sheet,
you want to what? Wake up earlier.
And you covered it too. No, no, no, no.
These are the, I'm saying, you know,
but here's the thing. It's
like, well it could cause, okay,
so it seems obvious, right?
You're trying to get in shape.
You're going to have hard days,
you know, days where you're like,
I'm going to skip the workout.
Right? No, it seems obvious.
That's an element of life on the
path that's, it seems obvious.
You'll run into like points of weakness
that's obvious and I dig it and there's
a track for that. Chocolate tells
you why you shouldn't do that.
You just listened to it.
Boom. Get it right back on
track. But I don't always do.
What I don't always talk about is that
this tracks for other things like the
creativity thing,
like if you got like a procrastination
situation. How's Allen?
The reason you're looking at me like
this is because you already know this,
but not everybody knows this.
You're procrastinating me finishing
this podcast and no, no, no.
We are finishing this podcast
strong with boatloads of value
because I'm lazy. I'm letting
people know this is what it is.
Say psychological warfare.
It's an album with tracks on iTunes,
MP3, Google play, Amazon music.
If you're going to run into some issues,
it'll help you out and get into
those issues. Next topic. Yeah, Eh,
I guess I could have said it like that.
That's more of like the Jocko way
to say it. You know, like I don't,
I feel like if I come from a place of,
you know,
authentic relation to the struggle,
I feel like it'll,
it'll,
it'll pass the message in a
more accurate way I think.
Okay. You don't skip
workouts. True. You do.
You okay, here's this. How's this?
Do you ever sit in your gym,
sit on the bench or whatever,
or the bike and be like, man,
if I am make deals with
yourself. Hey, if I skip today,
I'll just do a double.
I'll do is like,
if I'm doing something that's going to
suck like squats. Yeah, I'll, I'll, I'll,
I'll, I'll put, I'll procrastinate.
I'm in the gym like it's gonna happen.
Okay. But I'll like, okay,
let me just start talking.
But it's, it's one of those things
like the outcome is known. Yeah. Yeah.
The outcome is not in question.
The workout will happen.
I'm just being a complete baby about it.
Okay. So then I just have to suck it up.
Yeah.
So see,
that's why you're looking at me like
that because me and a lot of people like
me, we're not like that. We're trying to
be like that. We want to be like that.
I know. I do. I want
to be like skipping the
workout is straight up a non,
not an option ever. I want to, I, that's
a total wine. I want to be like that.
You won't let it happen,
but there are times and have been
times where I'm sitting there.
There's been times I drove
to the gym before I got my
own show, drove to the gym,
sad in there. It was like, look,
if I just walk right out of here right
now, he's skipped this workout I need.
I need Rick. I'm not going to get a
good workout anyway. Oh, you know what?
I'll just come back in on Saturday.
That was my active rest.
I'll come back in and I'll get it.
Then today will be my rest day. Right.
I'm like that. Some other people
were like that. You're not like that.
That's why you don't understand.
You know what I'm doing right now with,
I'm shuffling my papers, being passive
aggressive. I know it's very unlike you,
but you know, hey man, so good.
Nonetheless, psychological warfare.
I'm trying to make the make disappointed.
This is a for real point.
Okay.
Valuable point is the track that Jocko.
Hi Nick. Even though he tried to talk me
out of explaining this to you right now.
God,
he will talk you out to out of effectively
talk you out of skipping the word,
skipping the workout, talk you out
of pressing the snooze or whatever.
All these little points of weakness
gone there. Just if you look at them,
you'll see all the little
points of weakness that you,
that these tracks address.
It's good. Very effective. Cool.
Are we done with that section? Very good
way to port podcasts too. All alright.
Jocko white tea.
You can get that on Amazon.
It will guaranteed a hundred
percent double blind placebo,
a placebo tested triple, triple blind. Uh,
you can deadlift 8,000 lbs. So you
might want to pick that up on Amazon.
You can read them. If you don't
believe me, that's fine. Go read the,
go read the reviews on Amazon where every
verified purchase is like they're dead
lifting minimum 8,000 pounds. Books.
Got Some books way the warrior kid.
If you have a kid or you know,
a kid did help a kid,
okay.
Help them be a better person
to have a better life.
Get in the way of the warrior kid.
Extreme ownership.
The new edition is out and you all helped
write it because it has questions from
this podcast. Also, the new
forward, also the color pictures,
lame didn't want them
but made up for that by just making the
cover black because black and that book
has all the fundamental
principles of combat leadership.
It's for you and your team
do you don't need to hide it.
Remember in the beginning
people would want it,
they'd get it and they'd want
to key up for themselves.
They want to hide the knowledge because
they want to look. They want that.
Don't do that. It doesn't help. The more
people know it, the more people on board,
the better it's going to work.
Also from an individual perspective,
to get yourself on the path,
there's a book called discipline
equals freedom field manual.
It's available everywhere.
Okay,
and you might be wondering
if it would make a good
gift. Well, not only is it heavy,
have you noticed how heavy it is?
It's a heavy book. It's a big book.
It's a substantial book.
It's completely unique because it has
black pages and the outside of the pages
are also black to work of art for sure.
So get some copies for the people that
you know because beyond blue looking
really cool,
there is no better gift than discipline.
So I get some copies and also
if you want the audio version,
see now look,
I'm doing the same thing you just did
but let's watch how long this takes.
If you want the audio version of
discipline equals freedom field manual,
you can get it on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play and other MP3
platforms period. Right there.
Now everyone knows what you took 15
minutes to explain if you were in further
need of more fire support in
terms of basic leadership.
Okay.
Besides the Pont podcast,
beside the books and you want
to have more interaction,
take it to the next level. And we have a
leadership consulting company. It's me,
it's Leif Babin, it's JP
Denelle. It's Dave Burke.
Can email info@echelonfront.com and if
you have questions for us or you have
answers or you have directions
where you want to share something,
you can hit us up on the interwebs.
Twitter,
Instagram,
and
echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at jockowillink and
thanks to those people out there that give
us the freedom and protection
to make this podcast possible.
Our service men and women in uniform
protecting us from the enemy and fighting
the good fight.
Thank you.
And to the police and law enforcement
and firefighters and paramedics and the
rest of the first responders out there.
Thank you for answering
the call when we call
and to everyone out there,
there's an enemy
and whether that is a literal enemy
like our military personnel face or a
metaphorical enemy like
people face every day,
don't fear the enemy.
Respect the enemy and out of
your respect for the enemy.
Prepare.
Okay.
Prepare and train and learn and
stay vigilant and stay disciplined.
So when the enemy comes,
you are ready
to get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.